- [Gary] I think that
most people that are
not nice to other people,
are broken inside
and are unhappy inside.
And I think through
real psychological work,
therapy, real self-evaluation,
really hitting rock bottom,
some shock to the system
like taking a year vacation or
getting a divorce or having that
conversation with their father
about that thing that
happened when they were 11.
I mean there's a million things
that I do think
can unlock a dream.
I think they're the hardest
things in the world to do and
I don't take it lightly.
I've not been able to do it so
easily so I don't think it's
easy but I do
think it's achievable.
I think it takes an enormous
amount of self reflection,
acceptance and humility on the
part of the person that's doing
the actions and it takes a
complete reset of who they are
from a hardwiring standpoint
and so I would say yes,
but 99% of people
I don't think will pull it off.
And I mean that, by the way.
It's very hard.
(intense music)